as the corona virus pandemic caused
panic shoppers to clear out whole
supermarkets of toilet paper rice and
canned vegetables two brothers set out
on a 1,300 mile road trip through the
backroads of Kentucky and Tennessee Matt
and Noah Colvin loaded up a u-haul with
all the hand sanitizer and antibacterial
wipes they could find and they attempted
to resell the goods on Amazon at a
massive markup then the online retailing
giant banned the practice state
attorneys general started cracking down
and the Colvin's were shamed in the
media they ended up donating the items
but is so-called price gouging always a
bad Michael Munger who teaches economics
political science and public policy at
Duke University argues that prices
contained vital information about supply
and demand
when government's attempt to mandate
cheap goods he says they end up causing
more shortages than they solve and this
is especially true during a crisis I
spoke with Munger of I assume about how
the 21st century is testing libertarian
ideas about limited government and
individual freedom Michael Munger thanks
for talking to Reason it's a pleasure to
be on the show Nick okay and it's nice
that it's a show now you know because
what the one great thing that the
coronavirus has done is destroy all
standards of what is you know III don't
know where we go after this but you know
I'm happy to get in the car and drive
and pay for gas to get there Michael
Munger you are trained as an economist
you talk you teach public policy and
political science as well you are an
unapologetic defender of price gouging
can you explain what you why in in a
circumstance such as we're in now where
there is a lockdown the government says
you're not allowed to do certain things
you can only do other things here and
there why should we not suspend market
mechanisms the cost of things ranging
from n95 masks to toilet paper at
grocery store it's not clear that I
would defend price gouging in all
instances let me let me stat take a step
back
most most of us are not defenders of
cutting open someone's abdomen with the
razor blades I enlarged you shouldn't do
that but if they will otherwise die and
the surgeon can give them an
appendectomy you would say we're gonna
make an exception this is a really bad
circumstance under these limited
circumstances okay we would be better
off cutting open this person's abdomen
with the razor blade than not doing it
so I think price gouging is terrible and
much of what we call price gouging is
like a guy coming in telling an elderly
person this tree in your yard is gonna
fall down we'll cut it for you for $300
and they give him a bill for 2,000 so
much of what is enforced as price
gouging is in fact fraud so let's take
out fraud okay and recognize that we're
in a circumstance of really great
scarcity and let's think about what the
price mechanism does so if the price of
something goes up and there's a shortage
three great things happen the first is
that consumers buy less they look at
that price and they say you know
somebody else must need this more than I
do and so they leave some for the person
behind them the second thing is that
producers try to find ways to make more
and the third thing is that
entrepreneurs try to find ways to make
substitutes and the thing is that if you
use the price mechanism you don't have
to announce any of that all of it
happens automatically in a decentralized
way so the price mechanism is a signal
of scarcity it's not the cause of
scarcity it is a consequence of scarcity
and so there's people that would say
that if you live near a fire station I
hear sirens all the time it's really
upsetting we ought to outlaw sirens well
no the problem is the fire it's not the
siren so focusing on the price means
that you're if you want to keep prices
low I walk up I see low prices I say you
know I can take all I want and so the
reason why people take all this stuff is
the prices wait wait wait but that I you
know to push back on this you know that
isn't what happened a couple weeks ago
at grocery stores when people were like
there is a good chance that we are going
to be told not to leave our houses again
there is a good chance that trucks are
not going to be replenishing grocery
store shelves we went to buy toilet
paper because we're like we don't know
the next time we're gonna get it we did
that with meat we did that with rice and
grain so that is not you know I is it a
fairy tale to say oh well you know what
the price mechanism this mystical you
know invisible hand or invisible fist is
going to coordinate all of this stuff 72
hours from now three months from now
whatever how long is it I don't know how
you come up with substitutes for toilet
paper or you know who shifts out of odd
you know what right now I'm making
computer paper I'm gonna start making
toilet paper
how many months does that take to gear
up so can we talk about things in in in
a moment where you know a storm is
coming down and you you have a great
story about the long-forgotten hurricane
Fran from the ages ago 20th century and
about how shortages and whatnot played
out there but you know when a hurricane
is coming and we know we've got 24 hours
to get stuff and then it's all gonna be
gone
is it wrong to say to people you cannot
charge ten dollars for a one dollar
bottle of water or is it wrong or is it
is it a totally different thing to say
you know what we're not gonna mess with
the prices but you can't take the entire
aisle of toilet paper out of the grocery
store right now we're gonna limit you to
two or three just a couple of different
questions so first let me let me accept
the premise of one of your questions and
then quarrel with the premise of one of
your questions so the premise of your
question it's a very good one
is suppose that you're in a situation
where the things that I've talked about
are unlikely to be able to happen
because economists call this the supply
elasticity it's the responsiveness of
the amount of stuff so if this is really
all that we're going to have it means
that all of the second and third things
that I said we're good about prices
those can't happen and all we've got is
up
we're trying to allocate preferring to
allocate a scarce resource among a bunch
of people who want it and then they're
even there seems like a pretty good
objection that only rich people can buy
it so we really want a system that says
only rich people can I'm a I'm a rich
college professor I have tenure I still
have income of course I'm going to
advocate a system that benefits me I
want stuff to still be at the store and
have a really high price so if there's a
circumstance when this really is all
there is I can see an argument for some
other mechanism for some rationing we
would need and one way of rationing
would be and some stores have done this
no more than one or two containers of of
toilet paper on the other hand the
premise of your question is we don't
know when we're gonna get out again
nobody told you you weren't gonna get
out again and you can still go to the
grocery store and if you've been to the
grocery store lately at least in Raleigh
where I live there's plenty of toilet
base it's also the case in New York City
I have friends who live in various parts
of the country I know a virtually no one
who is saying you know what the shells
ran out three weeks ago and they haven't
been restocked yeah so there's a there's
a an old North Carolina joke about this
and it actually had to do with the
hurricane you mentioned hurricane Fran
but after the hurricane apparently some
guy goes into a 7-eleven and sees that
they have cases of water for $30 and
says $30 that's too much for water and
the guy says well yeah um you know it
that there's not much we're running out
and the guy the customer says but the
guy crossed the street
what are $7 ok go across the street and
buy a theater well he's out and so the
store owner says tell you what as soon
as I run out I'll charge $7 the point is
the only reason he had any was that he
was charging $30 the question is are you
better off $30 or a price of infinity
which is what you have when all the
prices are empty now that's still the
premise and the you ask the right
question what if it's true
that the supply elasticity meaning what
if it's true that this really is all
we're going to get
if if we're not going to get more with a
higher price there's a good argument for
rationing I agree with that it's just
that it's hard to think of a
circumstance although there are some and
that is masks and hand sanitizers for
frontline health care workers I think
there's an excellent argument for
declaring that those things are there's
a there's a national or state reason to
control those we're not going to allow
them to be sold we're not going to allow
rich people to buy them because they're
the only ones who can afford them and we
can't make enough more of those the
stockpiles are gone so for masks in New
York City yes those should not have high
prices those should go to frontline
health care workers and first responders
that's absolutely right what is the how
do we know what the elasticity of supply
or you know I guess at the same by the
same token demand is in a given
situation and this is where in the
current situation things seem a little
bit more unclear than in a classic kind
of hurricane situation where we know
there's a storm coming and it's going to
cut off all the roads all the supplies
how do we deal with something like this
and what were your first thoughts when
you heard you know mayors governors you
know federal officials saying okay you
know what we have to put in price
controls immediately because of you know
we know there are gonna be shortages I
think from a political perspective it
was a genius move because they can't do
anything that actually helps on the
virus or access to health care they
don't have enough testing kits they
screwed this up so what they can do is
say you know what we're gonna protect
people against price gouging my own
senator senator Thom Tillis who I've had
lunch with and has told me to my face
you know I'm a libertarian
yeah Thom Tillis and that's not Ben he
stuck you with the bill or what haha one
way or the other right I'm sure he has
introduced a piece of federal
legislation to outlaw federal price
gouging yeah so not only to ignore the
Tenth Amendment on local of police being
able to control
price so this is a federal price gouging
law it also ignores the fact that high
prices in one state are likely to bring
because not all states are equally
affected by this right it's need more
toilet paper some states really are
desperate for some of these items high
prices say bring it here we need it more
than you do and people will use the
implied profit to say alright we will
incur extra expense we'll get it there
faster and we'll get more of it so
prices nationally are an important
signal now if this were true that
everywhere we were all out everyone was
dying then we probably should have a
national rationing scheme but the way
that it is where different states are
different prices the fastest signal to
increase the amount of this stuff so I
think particularly at the federal level
of price gouging laws a mistake locally
if I were in New York I would fully
support a price gouging law and the
claim that we should use rationing that
doesn't involve prices that make sense
do we can you talk a little bit about in
New York City right now they're trying
to get nurses and other medical
professionals to come here they've done
you know what was unthinkable even a
month and a half ago which is they're
you know they're they're suspending or
waiving various kinds of certification
rules saying you know like you're
certified to help people in New Jersey
it's a totally different world in New
York so you have to go through a bunch
of regulatory hoops and all of that
they're saying okay screw that and we're
gonna pay you something like $100 an
hour as opposed to maybe $30 or $40 an
hour why do we not in general think of
labor as a source of gouging as well
because when contractors you know in
hurricane situations things like that we
kind of immediately reach for the idea
that if we pay more money we'll get
we'll get more of a supply it's really
an interesting distinction and I cannot
claim to understand it it in the in the
case of the healthcare workers they're
also being subjected to additional
danger and you're trying to get them to
commute from far away so it makes
perfect sense but people never say it
the way you said it which is we're using
price
increases to attract more of the needed
thing in this case it happens the needed
thing is labour so we seem to have we
seem to have a blind spot for the use of
price for commodities even though a
higher price does the three things that
I said but it's okay for labour
so I wouldn't say it's not okay for
labour right part we have right and
those people are taking great risks I
hope they get paid more they make they
probably are still underpaid right but
we should use the price mechanism for
other things where it's possible
provided it is we're now seeing an
increase in the production of toilet
paper there's there's a lot of these
commodities we're going to come online
with the production of hand sanitizer
and masks pretty soon so there is a
market response to this can you talk
about the ways in which government in a
way that it's not always credited often
creates these bottlenecks in production
and consumption so with something like
hand sanitizer I've read you know
distilleries are switching over to do
hand sanitizer but there are rules about
denaturing alcohol so that people don't
use rubbing alcohol to drink or
something like that what are some of the
hidden ways in which the government you
know kind of steps in to say okay we're
gonna help with this but they actually
are also part of the problem at the same
time it's probably unavoidable because
we were asking a system that is set up
to operate with things arriving just in
time because storing things are
expensive so we don't have big
stockpiles and then to blame the
government for not having stockpiled
things seems excessive right but the
government is also intentionally
unintentionally providing a bunch of
roadblocks in the form of just enforcing
the existing rules now the hard thing is
we probably don't want bureaucrats able
to suspend these rules at a whim because
they'll reward their friends and so the
the Food and Drug Administration for
nearly a month the entire month of
February enforced the rules
did you ously about testing kits so no
new testing kits were approved for a
full month and there were a number that
probably would have been okay but there
they had to do field testing and so the
Food and Drug Administration was doing
the job and had been assigned to do and
that's a disaster but the reason is
bureaucracy is actually designed to move
slowly and methodically to avoid things
like and we always use the same example
the letter might the United States
because it had the FDA didn't have the
lid imide because it was slow and
methodical so this is actually just a
feature of bureaucracy I wouldn't say
that it's a bug or something that's good
it's the way bureaucracy works sometimes
it saves us from precipitate decisions
that would have been bad and in this
case it's frustratingly preventing us
from being able to have access to the
stuff that we need you know one thing
that economists try to do is look at the
costs and benefits of you know
particular policies and the way they
play out it seems to me that in the
current discussion about the coronavirus
and this may make sense at this stage
but virtually the only thing we're
talking about is the potential cost in
terms of human life and the benefits of
saving as many people as possible or
flattening the curve whatever phrase you
want to use when do we when is it proper
to start factoring other economic issues
in such as you know we're looking at
something I was reading headlines that
over six million people have have
applied for unemployment benefits you
know which is almost double what the
initial estimate was going to be and you
know we're looking at we might be
looking at 25 percent or 30 percent
unemployment
this is depths of the great depression
level how do you from a kind of public
policy perspective factored in you know
economics that the larger economy versus
the immediate public health claims on
attention and things like that it's one
of the most difficult problems and when
I talk to students about this I it's
shocking to them but I tell them that a
public policy analyst particularly one
who teaches from the PPE perspective I'm
the director of philosophy politics and
economics from that
effective you have to realize that you
are not in favor of zero deaths mm-hm
and then it gets real quiet yeah I'm in
favor of a number of deaths that exceeds
zero if you add up the total of the
deaths from Co vyd and the deaths from
starvation or not having access to
economic resources or just the stress of
not knowing where you're going to work
those are always going to be a lot more
than zero I don't know where the minimum
is but it does seem like we have been
biased in favor
at first we were biased in favor of the
economy a lot of things did not shut
down we didn't get any kind of
distancing if you look at the curves
about rate of growth we blew right
through China and we're about to catch
Italy so the rate of increase of deaths
in the United States it's going really
badly and it seems that now we're likely
to react in the other direction of
overemphasizing so social distancing in
a way that really wrecks the economy
that made leave a legacy of years so the
consequence of that is that we we have
mismanaged this I think it's not like I
expected anything like this to happen
the effects on the economy are going to
be very hard to gauge and I do worry
that there's going to be a
centralization of economic power and
planning and the the idea of transfer or
in bailing out based on political power
some industries are going to get very
substantial bailouts some industries may
get almost nothing having that kind of
discretion in the hands of government
means that not only are we not going to
take care of the economy as much as we
might have but there's going to be
disparate treatment within different
industries and that's just a giant
rent-seeking contest so though it really
is about as bad as you can imagine what
you know a week ago basically Congress
passed and the President signed what is
generally considered or acknowledged to
be the single biggest spending bill in
American history probably in human
history you know two trillion dollars
plus in indirect money being shoveled at
various things what is your sense of
that and what is the role and this is a
separate thing you know what is it what
from a libertarian perspective
herminator explicitly
libertarian perspective what is the role
of the federal government in a situation
like this we're going to be able to talk
about this now for the rest of my life
in class because this is the best
example I've ever seen I don't know the
answer to your question okay
what's interesting is that I think that
way which which what is the libertarian
response or from a libertarian
perspective what would you be
comfortable with the federal government
doing well suppose that there is an
emergency of such great extent that
you're going to see Domino's where a
bunch of restaurants who owe money to
people who sell meat are unable to pay
their bills and then all of those are
unable to pay their debts and the banks
go down so there's this cascade maybe
because we've overreacted but for
whatever reason the libertarian response
my libertarian response is I'm a
utilitarian and I would like to try to
minimize the total number of deaths and
I don't know where the minimum of that
is we're trying to make a guess I would
say that the bill the legislation is
actually far better than I expected it's
more decentralized well you've got a
condition that on high expenses on my
expectations my expectations were really
bad this is mostly going to go to large
corporations a lot of it is going to go
directly and immediately to small
businesses without having to go through
an application process through the Small
Business Administration so they may be
able to keep some people on their
payrolls the big expense is if people
get laid off and then we have to go
through this really difficult process of
rehiring people so given that we were
going to do it I I don't know the answer
to what how much should a libertarian
think the federal government should do
given what they've done this is actually
pretty decentralized and pretty
non-bureaucratic is there going to be
fraud absolutely but a lot of this money
is actually going to get out pretty
quickly and it this is a way better bill
than I expected what was your feeling
about the financial bailout after the
financial crisis is this relative to
that this seems to be better
because it's going to smaller businesses
and individuals or and is the you know
is the function the same you know there
that was an idea how you know and I
think that was overhyped beyond belief
but the idea was that the economic
system was about to collapse we don't
really have that sense here right I
think that's that that's a good analogy
the problem that I would say is it
depends if you ask me when so if you ask
me in the fall of 2008 and the early
spring of 2009 did we have to do the
bailout that we did probably yes toxic
asset release program relief program we
probably did have to do because the
expectations that they would be built
bailed out were built into the way that
all these assets were capitalized if we
could have made a credible commitment in
2004 not to do a bailout then none of
that might have happened in the first
place and no bailout would have been
required but when we did not when we
fail to bail out Lehman Brothers there
was a catastrophe there really was a
very substantial decline so I guess it I
kind of think of if you have an
alcoholic relative question is how much
do you enable them it's absolutely true
that if they could get caught drunk
driving and wrap their tree around a
murder up their car around a tree should
you go bail them out or should you leave
them in jail well you probably go bail
them out but the question is how it was
there something before that some kind of
intervention that could have prevented
it so you've enabled them all this time
and then you say well we have to help
them now that's the wrong thing to think
but what you need to think is how can we
prevent that from having happened in the
first place
we did not make a credible commitment in
fact if you look at dodd-frank it
specifies like a list it specifies what
is a systemically important financial
institution or CP and says we will not
bail B's out if I were Salomon Brothers
I would say that's my to-do list what I
want to do is accomplish I want to make
sure I'm systemically important whereas
the restaurant on the corner is not
systemic ly important but it's locally
important there's five people who work
there
bailing them out means that there's a
pretty good chance that those five
people will continue to have jobs that
scales up in a way that paying off a few
people at the top doesn't so that
explains why you are more comfortable
with the current the cares Act that went
into effect last week we're comparing
levels of hell yeah
one is the fifth level and what is the
seventh level of hell but yes that that
legislation is better than I thought and
the two reasons are it's more
decentralized and it's less bureaucratic
what do you expect to happen to the
economy and you know part of this
depends on how long we're in lockdown
for but you know over the next two or
three months what is likely to happen
and then you know say come around
Christmastime where do you think we'll
be as as an economy I am I have such a
history of bad predictions I do have to
say that in November of this past year I
took all of my 401k and my wife's 401k
and converted it to money market so
we've been in cash in short-term bonds
since November and I felt like an idiot
for three months and now for two months
I felt pretty smart right and but it's
not because I knew anything it was
because it just looked like the system
was unsettled and so I think now
everyone agrees that the system is
unsettled it's going to be hard to find
money to invest the the the hospitality
industry restaurants hotels is just
wiped out and they may not be back
anytime soon
there are thousands and thousands and
thousands of people in every state who
work in the hospitality industry and
they're not going to be able to spend
money at Christmastime this this past
Christmas in some ways was not that
great next Christmas may be a
catastrophe so I don't know we're gonna
test a lot of the theories that can
ziens have about ways to try to spur the
economy so we may see a big increase in
the rate of growth of the money supply
we may see an attempt to start a bunch
of fiscal policy and we're probably
going to get one or more of those things
wrong so it big increase in debt or a
big increase in inflation
are quite possible what is you know are
there historical episodes that we can
look to not for you know predictive
value but for at least some kind of
analytic orientation World War two you
know and I'm thinking back to you know
our mutual friend and your regular
podcast partner and whatnot Russ Roberts
talking about hid the way he described
World War two Oh as an undergrad who
took economics classes in the 1980s I
was taught that you know the New Deal
was a good attempt to use Keynesianism
to restart the economy but it wasn't big
enough but then you know World War two
and all of the money and you know the
entire shifting of the American economy
to war footing is what finally got us
out of the Great Depression Russ Roberts
and other people say you know it didn't
do that at all when you look at economic
growth and also economic freedom you
know nobody had anything everything was
rationed and you couldn't do anything
and then in fact it was after World War
Two and an absolute steep decline you
know by I don't know what like two
thirds or something of federal spending
in the in the 40s that's when the
economy took off you know can we look at
World War two and the effect both under
lock down and then post-war as some
marker for what's going to happen or I
had you know how do we even come up with
scenarios that are not just wish you
know fantasies here I cannot think of an
analogy the closest analogy I can think
of to for people living almost under
lockdown was the polio epidemic of the
early in mid 50s so in many parts of the
Midwest people just stayed home in fact
they had to stay in their own bedrooms
if you know polio is only for young
people but I was catastrophic so before
the Salk vaccine became widely available
and if you look at the economic effect
on states where there was the where the
polio vaccine was running wild it was
terrible but it was relatively brief it
was a couple of years and by then it
moved on to somewhere else the world war
two question is it is true that an awful
lot of resources were employed in fact
the in in the rap video if you use
and all your money on the Army in Fleet
you have full employment but nothing to
eat right so you're not actually
producing anything but there still was
income so people did have income there
was full employment here we're not going
to be producing anything and people will
not be employed so they won't have any
source of income even if it's fake
income like it was in World War two
because there was nothing I could buy as
things were rationed we may move to
rationing some things if people don't
have enough money to buy an essentials
so I guess that my my big worry is in in
big cities like New York if the
unemployment rate is 30 or 40 percent
we're probably going to move to soup
wines and ration coupons where you can
get things like WIC coupons except now
it won't be women and infant children
it'll be anyone who's unemployed so the
we will we will move towards rationing
of a more socialist kind because the
alternative is revolution and the cities
will be on fire do you think it's likely
I mean end you know god we're only a few
weeks into any of this but the
productive capacity doesn't seem to have
slowed down as we were talking about you
know the grocery store shelves are full
again do you think if this continues
that actually we won't be able to grow
food or bring it to market or things
like that or is are we talking about
something different here where it's the
food will be there and it's just that a
large number of people and unfathomable
unfathomable percentage of people won't
have any money to buy stuff with yes
that it is the production part of the
economy is behaving pretty well and we
are restocking the shelves that we're
gonna have a we're gonna have a problem
in the fall because there's not enough
workers to be able to harvest crops but
but but for now we're still in last year
we have plenty of food to be able to
distribute but if you're not able to pay
your rent then you can have a law for a
little while that there'll be no
evictions but that's a really short run
problem because the landlord is going to
get evicted that the landlord has to
make the nut on the note that the
landlord is paying every month and in
the big cities that in New York that in
Washington DC San Francisco that's a lot
of money so and that is just
we could decree that no one can be
evicted so they still have housing for a
little while they have absolutely no way
of buying food they have no hope of
getting a job to buy food and in fact
they can't leave their apartment so I I
do think that in the what's going to
break the binding constraint is not
we're going to run out of things to buy
but people are going to get tired of not
being able to buy them not having any
income thirty or forty percent
unemployment with no income coming in
you get a thousand dollars from the
government that doesn't help very much
do you how likely do you think that
scenario is I would guess that in the
large cities we will have rationing we
will have rationing of the sort to
ensure that people with no money can get
basics rice beans you know when vaccines
come online for this is there a strong
argument you know you were talking we
started out talking about how price
signals help you know create more of a
supply which ultimately lowers the
prices so a spike in prices now can
actually guarantee or our health you
know people have ubiquitous access to a
good later when a vaccine comes online
should that be free or should or should
it be free to the person getting it
should that be something that the
government actually makes sure gets to
everybody one solution might be to pay
people to get the vaccine so we can
never because the developing herd
immunity as fast as possible is our goal
and no having a vaccine in combination
with a test to be to be able to tell
whether you've had it so if we have a
test that could detect the presence of
antibodies because some people are going
to have it and not know it
they don't need the vaccine so if we can
develop two things an effective vaccine
and a test to find out whether people
have antibodies present and we can make
sure that ninety seven percent of the
population has met one of those two
conditions the disease is over we're
done although it may be that it comes
back in a year or two it's not clear how
long the antibodies last for coronavirus
so it's it's not like chickenpox where
basically you have immunity for years
and years
afterwards but if we can have those two
things in tandem I would say that the
vaccine probably we should pay people to
take the vaccine and have as many people
as possible you know one of the one of
the hopes I think of the current moment
is you know just as the FDA and the CDC
and various local and state authorities
are giving up kind of stupid regulations
that don't seem to be working at all
that we're going to experiment a lot and
do that I mean realistically I mean
you're you're talking about a major
shift from in the past it was you cannot
come in here unless you can certify that
you have been inoculated against
something I've we have kids you can't go
to schools unless you show a vaccination
list and all of that now you suddenly
you're talking about paying people to
get vaccinated or to you know take a
test to show that they're in
realistically are we really gonna change
you know 200 years of public policy in
America over this kind of stuff and if
so how do we how do we grease the skids
for that kind of activity I think that
economic misery is going to make people
a lot more susceptible to it because
again just as we said there's going to
be deaths no matter what there's going
to be economic costs no matter what so
is there a way we can choose that will
minimize the total economic misery and I
think this will be less expensive then
letting the thing run its course and not
the longer this goes on the longer we
extend the the period in which we're
economically inert and there'll be a
there's there's no fundamental problems
dynamically we should start to respond
on the other end there's be a lot of
pent up demand for all sorts of home
repairs of construction people will want
to go on vacations so the sooner we can
get through that the better now I
realize that that sort of argument is
always made by the left and I feel a
little odd making it know it's gonna pay
for itself that if we do this if we're
actually going to make money by spending
this but it's actually true that herd
immunity is a different kind of public
good if we can get to 97 percent we're
in a fundamentally different world than
if we're at 80 percent talked a bit
about
whether or not you know this moment
which you know we're about the same age
we're in our late 30s right yeah with 30
years experience yes and but you know
this is certainly the most I was gonna
say the most unique it's it is a
completely novel and unique experience
it's not like the financial crisis it is
not like 9/11 it's not like the Cold War
and at various hot points there this is
a weird Black Swan you know what hopes
it's a Black Swan and it doesn't become
just the new normal all of this you know
how does this affect your libertarian
predispositions does it fundamentally
challenge things or does it you know
magically as often is the case for any
ideological persuasion you know have all
of your you know political commitments
suddenly been validated by what's going
on here talking I mean and I and I guess
I'm sorry to go on it so long as a
prologue to this you know immediately
upon this first becoming recognized as a
problem you know you started seeing
headlines saying there are no
libertarians and in pandemics and then
you know I know reason at other places
published stories almost immediately the
first you know time a rule was suspended
and people were like I just go about
your business it was like now there are
only libertarians and pandemics where
are you on any of this Michael almost
everyone has seen their predispositions
validated by what has happened and so we
used we use the evidence selectively to
support what we believed already but I
have to admit I came to realize that I
had a view on this January first my good
friend Tyler Cowen wrote a piece on
state capacity libertarianism and I
recently wrote a coming out story of my
own how state capacity libertarianism
makes a lot of sense it seems to me we
need to have a healthy skepticism about
the scope of the functions of the state
and the the state has metastasized into
so many areas where it has no business
so as a result it does a pretty bad job
in almost all of them so it's trying to
do everything and as a result can't do
anything can you right and we
need it to do something now right I mean
this is uh you know I'm broadly in the
same camp that you know I'm not an
anarchist I think the government is
legitimate and it should do fewer things
well rather than everything kind of in a
half-assed way
can you put some meat on those bones
what are the things the government
should be doing and what are the things
that should say you know what we we got
a we got to just leave this to the
markets or to nonprofits or something
else well there's a short run in the
long run so let's think about the short
run for a second suppose that like many
of my libertarian colleagues one
believes that the Food and Drug
Administration is unnecessary brand
names brand names trademarks reputation
that could solve all of that problem we
could have something like underwriters
laboratories a private organization that
will check to see if drugs work all
right you can believe that we have the
FDA the question is does starving the
Beast help should we cut the budget of
the FDA does that get us closer to
Liberto Pia no given that we have the
FDA given that that's the system the FDA
needs to be well-funded and to have
these other rules eliminated so that's
actually consistent with the libertarian
view we should liberalize the rules at
the FDA but it should be well funded it
should have a lot of experts it should
be an exciting place to work people who
want to commit to public health is it
but isn't that what the CDC you know
that is always given high marks for a
government agency and it's explicitly
designed to help stave off exactly what
we're in and you know Donald Trump may
have tried to defund certain aspects of
it but its budget continues to go up and
it's hasn't it been shown to be you know
not just an effective but cock-blocking
other people who were actually trying to
get get something done yeah I'm I'm I'm
I'm willing to say that and that's the
second part in the short run we should
not just be across the board trying to
cut I have many libertarian friends that
say anything that smaller government is
better that's not true it's just not
true we need to be selective in the long
run we do need to try to say we need to
have a serious conversation particularly
about X
I would like to zero out the budget of
some agencies and something what is an
agency that you would say like you're
done well number one the TSA should be
private other countries the the air
traffic control should be private most
other countries again don't have
homeland security many parts of ice
should not exist there's no reason for
us to have domestic spying to have of
interrogations of people that are
hundreds of miles inland we want to
control the border okay I mean that that
we could argue about the extent but
they're just enforcing the law but we
have a lot of enforcement and spying
activity as a result of the aftermath of
9/11 the expansion of the Patriot Act so
there's a bunch of activities that the
government engages in and some of that
at the local level is just nanny ism
where you're you're it might not even be
money it isn't so much spending as the
scope of regulation so attempts to make
sure with local zoning that you cannot
build houses in San Francisco and then
complain about the absence of low-cost
housing have a requirement where you
have to have 1.75 parking spaces per new
a apartment so there's a lot of
regulations we could get rid of there's
a lot of things that we could zero out
and then what's left should be
well-funded right let's talk a little
bit about your line of work and you know
regardless of the coronavirus you know
in a lot of ways the the kind of model
of a four-year residential college with
tenured faculty
I'd say there's a strong argument that
you know first off that hasn't been
around for as long as people think it's
really a post-war and it's more like a
post increase in state universities in
the 50s till now it's dying anyway the
number of tenure faculty positions in
many areas dying out but this is a shock
the coronavirus you know pandemic and
the lockdown is as much a shock to
higher education as it is to any
possible part of the economy you have
written eyes
last time that we talked that length it
was about your fantastic book about the
future of work the future of labor in a
you know in a kind of sharing economy
and whatnot talk a little bit about how
your daily work life has changed because
of this and you know in the fall is Duke
or other colleges are they going to be
open for business as usual or is it is
this a moment where you know they're the
you know that the butterfly was trying
to come out of the caterpillars
chrysalis or whatever for a long time is
this finally the the moment where a lot
of what we took for granted as higher ed
just kind of disappears we could do a
whole hour-long podcast about this I
think it's an interesting question I
just submitted a piece to a national
magazine they haven't accepted yet so I
won't say one but I just submitted a
piece to a national magazine about the
future of higher education I think this
is going to be a Rubicon we're going to
cross over and this experience for many
students is going to give the lie to the
idea that you have to show up on campus
and be educated at a particular time so
there's the the tyranny of the clock
tower you can only be educated between
10 a.m. and 11:15 on Tuesday and
Thursday instead of having things that
are asynchronous you can watch this
video you can watch it two or three
times I think that we're gonna look back
on this as a big change in higher
education however it is true that that
not now but two months ago in New York
City in one day you could see a movie in
the morning you could watch Netflix in
your apartment in the afternoon and you
could go to a live play on Broadway in
the evening so all of these things doing
it live in a group doing it individually
and then watching a video as a group and
having a discussion all of those things
can happen in it that the the tyranny of
the top universities probably will
continue tyrannies the wrong word the
dominance of the top universe because of
the signaling value of going to an elite
university but
many many other people there is no
reason why University should have the
gatekeeping role that they do we should
make education something that's more
depth democratized well and it's become
that certainly since World War two and
I'd argue you know in a weird way and I
guess this is something that a lot of
libertarian thought doesn't dwell on but
simultaneously a school like Duke or you
know a you know whatever you want to
call it a top 25 university may have
more cachet now but people have more
ways of totally ignoring that than ever
before the New York Times the people
there are paid more they have higher
status than ever and it's also like the
New York Times can't close down Broadway
plays with a shitty review anymore so we
have these things that are moving in the
same you know in in directions that
don't seem to add up let me ask you this
about a higher ed though and
particularly when you're talking about
certain social sciences and the
humanities you know we tend to talk
about higher ed as if it's only a place
where undergraduates go and you know
learn you know the all the best that has
been thought and said and all of that
kind of stuff in fact I would argue that
the main function or the the real
utility of a university of a research
university is the work that the faculty
do how do you see that changing if you
know suddenly people don't have to be
going to colleges as much and department
budgets you don't need as many
professors you cut the budget the
professors are expected to teach more do
less research what's what is the large
impact of that kind of act that kind of
shift that could really be a big deal
because a lot of the research that's
done in humanities departments is just
done as a means to an end to getting
tenure which is done as a means to an
end to having the rankings of your
university improved and it's more like a
computer game than anything real the
amodal number of references to a lot of
these published articles is zero no one
ever reads them right and so the way
that we have research structured is
because it's a tied good to education -
education forgive me
to participating in what it is we do in
the classroom and so breaking those
things apart I'm not sure that there
would be that much demand and I'll just
stick to my own discipline right if you
had to sell research in political
science on its own I'm not sure anybody
would pay for that but we get paid a lot
to do research in political science
because we're in a political science
department at a top university but if
it's don't you think that you're a
better teacher because you're actively
doing research whether or not that
research is going to produce a patent
that you can sell to a corporation you
know it's besides the point I mean there
is I think a link between smart people
doing research being better in the
classroom which then attracts more
people I think that that is true for
many of the it is true that many of the
best teachers are also good researchers
however what I was saying was that a lot
of the research that is actually
published it is hard to say what its
value is
so the doing research and staying
current in your field is a good way to
be better teachers and that's working
fine I think but I would say that but
that's working pretty well at the top
universities but there's a lot of
universities that are large state
universities that are what we we call
them it's derogatory we call them
directional University so they have they
have a direct piece Carolina yeah Norah
well let's say you're at Duke let's say
North Carolina yeah it's a directional
State University yeah that is I've never
thought of that before but I'm going to
use it a lot from now on thank you
though they're there they're teaching
four classes a semester and they do get
to do some research but if we could
break that off and have them use a video
from a professor who is really great at
doing this something like the equivalent
of movie stars and they have a
discussion about it that might be better
than expecting them to do lectures on
their own so we're trapped in this
narrative about the sage on the stage
and with the new technology allows us to
break that up and have it be more
modular so creativity and teaching
be more important than having research
informed teaching that we can probably
only afford at the top places what what
about other forms of labor
you know this year started or really
over the past year in California there
was a law that was passed you know to
help supposedly uber drivers and lyft
drivers and people delivering for Grubb
other seamless or whatever you know a
law that basically banned freelancing in
the name of saying you know what the the
grand bargain between employer and
employee that was hammered out in the
fat years after World War Two and the
the great compression you know this
mythical period that never really
existed but we're constantly referencing
that our parents our grandparents you
know worked for one company forever and
they got a fully-loaded health benefit
plan they got a Cadillac retirement and
that's how it should always be you know
in California was leading the way and
saying we're forcing companies to do
that again your book from a couple years
ago is it and I'm blanking on the title
it's got three morrow
it's tomorrow 3.0 3.0 I knew it had 3.0
and it's Martha know was actually
extolling the virtues of the gig economy
or of you know more modular kind of
hammer you know individually tailored
work arrangements what's gonna happen do
you think you know when we're on the
other side of this regarding your vision
of the future well and it connects with
the coronavirus and social distancing
because it means that there we need more
flexibility in labor markets so last
week
I wrote some land that nothing better
for your book than the coronavirus yeah
I'm in investigating though selfish
Michael's under so so so precious
yeah I wrote a letter I'm working with
the independent Institute Institute in
Oakland California to have a letter for
California economists and policy
analysts to ask the governor of
California to suspend assembly bill five
so Assembly Bill five was the
legislation that basically said a set of
requirements and it really effect
Reiter's the the tough thing about a b5
was that if you published at first it
was more than 20 and then it became more
than 32 pieces per year for the same
magazine well if you have a weekly
column
you're gonna publish 30 yeah you do have
to be a full-time staff or etc which
means which means that they wouldn't let
you write the reaction was not to hire
them as a full-time staff for with
benefits the reaction perfectly
understandably was to say alright you
can't write more than this limit and so
we're gonna try to get governor Newsom
to suspend a b5 for as long as the
corona virus is keeping social
distancing because it we need people to
be able to work in part-time jobs so
they can get by until full-time jobs
start to come back they may or may not
ever come back I think a b5 should be
rescinded
yeah but it should it should clearly be
suspended in the short run because
ability to use apps and gig jobs to get
through are going to be the key to
reducing the damage economically what do
you think about the argument that a
fairly massive federal unemployment
benefits in the decares Act and the two
trillion dollar spending bill that was
passed plus the you know monthly stipend
essentially going to people may
individuals and children you know in
households making under 75 grand a year
is actually going to push companies to
fire people or to at least furlough them
do you think yeah are we paying people
to not work effectively and that means
you know what that's up that's a pretty
good bargain for everybody I think that
companies recognize how expensive it is
to hire new people and so they'll
probably try to keep them on if they can
but restrictions like a b5 that mean
that there's a high minimum wage you
have to continue to pay benefits if you
could keep them on in a furloughed
capacity for a longer time it's more
likely you would continue to have a
predictable relationship with that
company it is true that some companies
may say you know you're you're getting
enough from outside we're just going to
you often not pay you anything I think
that's a hard calculus and there are so
many different businesses and different
sized businesses I have talked to some
people recently that are now they stayed
home for a bit they took unpaid leave
and the company is saying maybe because
they had symptoms the company is saying
you have to come back or you're going to
be we're going to treat you as if you
resign because you refuse to come to
work they're in a very difficult spot
the companies can't continue to offer
benefits for free but the people don't
feel like they can go back to work do
you know one of the most kind of
annoying and frustrating conversations
we've had as a nation for you know 20
years a minimum it's longer than that
but especially you know in the past 10
or 15 years revolving around Obamacare
in health care a lot of us wanted to
delink health care and health insurance
from employment because you know among
just from the employer point of view
they don't know you know how to run a
health care insurance plan and it you
know it's it's difficult it's a drain on
them and they're gonna get a crappy deal
for their employees employees want to be
able to move from job to job with that
saying you know I hate my I'm working in
a coal mine but you know the benefits
are good so I'm not gonna you know
become a supermodel or something like
that where are we in terms of D linking
that now because you know we have on a
certain level we've been told her the
Trump administration has said you know
they're not gonna reopen the Obamacare
exchanges Obamacare didn't really get us
very far along the line we can argue
about why or why not
the idea that the government should be
more involved in it in a system that it
already spends half of the dollars that
are spent on and is does a kind of bad
job in the in the areas that it directly
oversees you know how does health care
and the relationship to work where
government come out of the coronavirus
lockdown this is gonna break it so
regardless of which side you're on I
think empirically it's going to break
our ability to link them because people
like me that have a secure job
I will also have secure health care a
lot of people that really need health
care when they lose
job won't have it and their access to it
was not improved that much by Obamacare
Obamacare was basically written by the
few elites we didn't really even then
achieve of 100% coverage there's there's
at least one former editor of recent
magazine who was actually expressed
admiration for the French system with
you a single-payer health care system
and I wonder if something like the
German system might be a compromise so
it would take it would be a big and
wrenching change to have individual
health care accounts that are tax-free
that we then top-up the German system is
basically a voucher system so there's
there's five companies that provide
insurance and if you can't pay enough
into it it'll be topped up but then
there's competitive private provision so
I'm worried that we'll move to something
like a national health system that we
see in England whereas the German system
yeah it's not perhaps that's not utopian
but it it harnesses some good elements
like well versal coverage but also
market forces week we libertarians
shouldn't speak for everyone I myself
find that a compromise in education is
government financing and private
provision right so a voucher system so
the German system is universal public
financing but competitive private
provision right and that may be the best
that we can hope for because having a
lot of people without health care and
having that sense of precariousness also
being locked into jobs that haven't
happened to have benefits it is not
worked out very well and the fact that
employment is going to be so high means
that the question that you just asked I
would guess that that's going to be a
national conversation within two months
so just as a kind of final topic of
conversation you know can you take a
long view of you know and I know from
previous conversations you grew up under
you know not exactly plush circumstances
and you know in the American century in
the meat of the American Century you
like myself I think looked forward to
the 21st century you know this if it
wasn't gonna be jetpacks it was gonna be
you know at least this right I mean
so this is kind of cool this is Dick
Tracy you know TV watch stuff like that
but it seems like the 21st century you
know first starting with the kind of
nightmare of an election really that was
basically came down to a coin flip and
then suddenly when you go back and you
have to count every vote and you just
realized like wow this reality is kind
of goopy and filled with all kinds of
weird [ __ ] going on then 9/11 you know
then a nightmare I mean with with you
know prosecuted 9 Allah of the wars
after 9/11 prosecuted by baby boomers of
all people who cut their teeth you know
being anti-war the financial crisis now
this what is your sense of the future of
optimism and you know does you know does
libertarian does a libertarian
sensibility do you think actually offer
much to a vision of the future where is
it one of those weird ossified artifacts
of you know mid-century prosperity that
just you know is is irrelevant to to
what it what to the world that our kids
and grandkids are gonna be paying for in
2008 when I was the keynote speaker for
the libertarian national convention in
Denver the the theme of my speech was
what are we for you know I wanted to ask
what optimistic positive view of the
future are we able to offer because
libertarians are usually against things
if you were to ask there's always some
laundry list of things that were against
and I guess I think the optimistic part
of the libertarian vision is that we
think that there's a lot of human
creativity and resilience in the face of
catastrophe and that left to their own
devices people are pretty cooperative on
the other hand libertarians tend not to
be utopian we're don't think we can
accomplish all sorts of things that
socialism promises or that other M isms
promise we're going to just try to
muddle through so I guess that's a
that's a very limited kind of optimism
but I do think that there's a lot of
people that I have talked to have
started to think all right what happen
at the other end how can we start to
plan for this and we we're not going to
come out of it better than we were this
is going to be a scar and a limitation
on what we can accomplish for a decade
or more
but the things are rarely so bad that
aggressive intervention by the state
can't make them worse
all right well is there a particular
signal a bad sign you know that signal
in the air that you're looking for that
says okay this is the time when we start
opening things back up I used to think
that it would happen fairly quickly once
quite a few people who have the virus
are starting to come out the other end
so once the number of people who are
starting to recover approximates the
number of new people that are catching
it each week then that's the turning
point but if you look at the the New
York Times has a page that I look at
every morning on a log scale and the
rate of increase of deaths in the United
States it's still linear and linear on a
log scale means it's doubling so it's
still doubling every three days we're a
long way from getting to the point even
where we can say we're at the beginning
of the end so we're a month or more even
from starting a downturn in the rate of
increase and I did not expect that this
is far worse than I had anticipated
maybe it was anticipated well maybe I
wasn't paying enough attention you know
I'm teaching my classes and I'm reading
things but we're a month or more even
from the beginning of the end all right
well we're gonna leave it there Mike
monger of Duke University thank you so
much for talking to Reason and sharing
your thoughts about public health
economics and the future of work and
higher education it was great to talk to
you Nick
you